so now after the nomination of amy coney
barrett to the supreme court and
literally
as the new york times story exposing
donald trump's taxes was breaking donald
trump held
a press briefing and this was a very
haphazardly
scheduled press briefing it was sunday
in fact donald trump was golfing when
the press briefing was scheduled just a
few hours before
and although we don't know because they
don't tell us it's reasonable to
speculate that a last-minute press
briefing scheduled on a sunday
while donald trump is golfing may well
be to try to generate news and take
attention away from the breaking story
in the new york times
uh also completely plausible that the
trump administration knew it was going
to be published at least a few hours
before it was published so
needless to say donald trump holds a
press briefing
and it's completely pathetic it's
gaslighting it's delusional
it's perverse let's look at some of it
let's look at how dangerous
this is donald trump still it's like
he's taking attention away from the tax
story by saying horrible authoritarian
things
trump still won't commit to voluntarily
leaving office if he loses
we all believe in transition but not
when the system is rigged
he says now i do apologize for the bad
audio quality of these clips something
was wrong with the audio
in the transmission it's it's not on our
end but let's take a look at this first
one
and it's very dangerous for our country
so
certainly transition we all believe in
transition we believe
not only in transition but very friendly
but when the ballots and when the system
is rigged which it is obviously it is
and the only one that knows that better
than me are the democrats
and they go into closed rooms and they
must laugh like hell
at what's going on because these ballots
are being found and this is the
beginning
i talk about it now at the rallies all
these people are watching
eyes and ears thousands and thousands
tens of thousands
but there's no justification for these
extreme changes to the election law he
says
when it's rigged and that it's rigged
this time well then it's a different
situation you don't just commit to a
peaceful transition when it's rigged
then he says it is indeed rigged
remember there are no extreme changes to
election law
the way he says all we've done is
expand the list of valid reasons for
voting absentee
in some states sending people an
absentee ballot application
which they can fill out and send back if
they want an absentee ballot has been
expanded
but there have been no radical or
extreme changes
so then the questions actually start
about the new york times tax story
and trump first just sort of weirdly
denies it all
but doesn't make any sense completely
collapsing under just basic questioning
frankly everybody's going to talk about
there's a new york times story that came
out about an hour ago
that says that when you came to the
white house you were paying about 750
a year in federal income tax they are
not releasing they're not publishing the
tax
returns they're not showing that out
there they're saying to
protect their sources your tax return
sir does that sound right if you're
paying a couple hundred dollars a year
with no income taxes
fake news it's totally fake news made up
fake
we went through the same stories you
could ask me the same questions four
years ago i had to litigate this and
talk about it
uh totally fake news now actually i paid
tax but and you'll see that as soon as
my tax returns
it's underwater they've been underwater
for a long time
the irs does not treat me well they
treat me like the tea party like they
treated the tea party
and they don't treat me well they treat
me very badly
you have people that in the irs very
they treat me very very badly
but they're underwater so trump is asked
about his taxes
and he simply says it's fake now i do
think
that eventually the new york times might
have to figure out how do you release
the actual documents
while protecting the identity of their
source so trump can't keep calling it
fake news
for now the new york times has reported
on the contents of the tax documents but
they've said
uh we can't release the documents
because it would potentially expose our
source and for now trump can say it's
just fake
at some point if the new york times can
figure out how to release the docs
without endangering or exposing their
source that would be a good thing
then trump is asked again about the
taxes and listen to how pathetically
weak
his pushback is about the tax returns
story though you have to understand that
when americans read that you may have
paid only a few hundred dollars in
federal income tax per year
that seems very low for someone who's a
billionaire
so how much i mean basically they're
saying i paid nothing can you give
people an idea of how much you actually
are paying
yeah basically well first of all i paid
a lot and i paid a lot of state income
taxes too
uh the new york state charges a lot and
i paid a lot of money at state uh
it'll all be revealed it's going to come
out but after the audit is
after the how much are you really paying
he says oh i'm paying a lot
and you know i pay state taxes as well
how
interesting that now trump has gone
back to this talking point of oh when my
audits are done we're going to release
the information which was what he said
in 2015 that's what he said in 2016 and
then of course
just stopped saying once he became
president of the united states
this story now it's not forcing him to
actually disclose anything
but it has pushed him to again go back
to well
once my audits are done we're going to
disclose on everything it's just
complete gaslighting and anybody who's
falling for
it at this point what planet have you
been living on for the last four years
donald trump then was asked about does
he really think
that joe biden is using drugs to better
perform during debates we'll talk about
that a little bit later
and trump says yeah i'm not joking which
we should know trump doesn't tell jokes
you said this numerous times but do you
really believe that joe biden will be on
any type of performance enhancing drug
ahead of the debates
or are you just joking i'm not joking i
mean
i'm willing to take a drug test i think
he should too because he's had a very
uneven i watched him with some of the
when he was with you know debating
pocahontas and
harris who treated him so badly but i
watched him
and he was out of it right and then i
watched him against
bernie sanders that he was okay i mean
he wasn't great
but he wasn't terrible he was okay
a far cry from the way he you know what
i'm saying i mean if you look at some of
those debates
i said there's no way he can continue he
can't continue
then all of a sudden he debated crazy
bernie sanders and you know what the
truth is he was
he was okay this is a president talking
this way
no other country at our level of
development or even below it would allow
this and yet it's daily here in the
united states
and trump continuing to push this asked
for sources on joe biden juicing
says oh just look at the internet a
president asked for facts says
look at the internet okay and i said how
did he go from there
with those horrible performances to
where he was
okay and i always joke but you know it
is true he was no winston churchill
in debating but he was fine and
people say he was on performance
enhancing drugs a lot of people have
said that a lot of people
have written that so so let's take a
look at it
take a look why don't you just check it
and you can check out the internet
you'll see plenty of people say it
now finally trump is saying something
true which is that
you can find people on the internet
saying biden use drugs
you can find people on the internet
saying the earth is flat
you can find people on the internet
saying obama is a reptilian not of this
earth
trump is finally right about something
you can find just about any
nonsense you want on the internet and
then trump continuing to lie about his
crowd size
again suggesting there were 30 or 35 000
people at a recent rally there were 4
000 people there remember
you know that i don't know if it would
have been reported before but all of
these rallies those you know we had
thousands of people last night as you
know
and we're in harrisburg pennsylvania uh
the night before we were in virginia
i mean those crowds are whether it was
35 000 or
30 those crowds are massive and that's
on very short notice
all of those people are watching you
know we have eyes and ears now that
we wouldn't have had if we didn't bring
it up so no i'm sure she's watching and
i'm sure that everybody's looking at it
i think
i think it's just common sense go ahead
it's just lie about the big stuff
lie about the small stuff lie all the
time and then one more thing
this every every time this happens it's
it's just a reminder
that presidents sometimes can talk about
policy
trump can't trump was asked about the
conflict
between armenia and azerbaijan and he
can do nothing other than to say
we're looking at it very strongly it's
it's a meme now but that's actually what
he said
mr president thank you mr president
um
[Music]
good thank you and there has been uh
going on the military action in the
carnival azerbaijan and
where the azerbaijan yeah the karabakh
and the civilians are killed and
according to the officials from the
azerbaijan they
say the first fruit came from the
armenian what's your comment on that so
we're looking at it very strongly just
happened and
i know about it i learned about it today
and
yesterday and we're looking at it very
strongly
we have a lot of good relationships in
that area we'll see if we can stop it
okay thank you very much everybody in
ten of the
previous 15 years before the 2016
elections you played zero dollars
just 25 unable to speak in depth
about any issue so this
is now maybe the story through the
election or maybe not
is this the october surprise the trump
tax story
that came a few days early or is
something even crazier going to break
between now and the
election i don't even i don't even have
any interest nor ability to guess
anything could happen
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now and
thankfully
there's a practical and affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with no other fees or
copays
there are so many practical advantages
to using steady md for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched
me with a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
there's no risk no commitment to get
started just click the link right
underneath this video